for the curry paste add chopped
lemongrass chili fresh ginger garlic and
kaffir lime leaf to a pestle and mortar
next put an aromatic ground cinnamon and
coriander a pinch of salt black pepper
and bash it into a rough paste finally
add olive oil to loosen and your paste
is done now onto the pork neck add a
glug of olive oil to a hot pan and brown
the diced meat carefully
thank you sure each side hits the heat
locking in that flavor removed and in
the same pan cook sliced onions until
brown around the edges at the curry
paste and fry to release all the intense
flavors then put the pork back in along
with a coconut milk and stir
next add chicken stock palm sugar more
kaffir lime leaves soy sauce and fish
sauce to taste then simply simmer for an
hour
[Music]
slow-cooked for succulents spicy super
easy to make and wonderful serve with
fresh mango salsa pork make curry pan on
get that nice and hot you think of the
sort of density of a pork chop how it
needs a little bit of health sweet sound
peppers don't burn any well first slice
the peppers that's the flat side of the
pepper so stand it up try to slice a
pepper on the side is a nightmare
there's the center start off it's almost
like sort of peeling an orange go all
the way around and down and look this
one now pace the pepper down the stree
finger rule one thing you're in front to
behind pinkie holding it down thumb hold
it nice and flat the flatter the
vegetables the more confident you are
when you slice so don't worry about the
speed just let the knife do the work and
take your time
speed tons the most important thing just
get your technique right going in now
swings our peppers olive oil in
I'm going to sew to them which is just
the chef's term for shallow fried on a
high heat for maximum taste salt and
pepper add a tablespoon of sugar sugar
helps to break down the peppers quicker
but caramelize the onions find them in a
frying pan
perfect there's one of those sort of
basic essential tools of any kitchen
because it's so multi-purpose great for
so tang tossing great for cooking fresh
and neat push away and pull back push
away and put back that hissing there's
something you need to hear constantly
because the minute that's gone your
peppers and your onions start to boil
and you really want them to start it you
now start to see listening the way that
it's time to camera eyes Sugar's working
usually that's ready pour the red wine
vinegar then smells incredible it helps
to stain the peppers as well look at the
glaze now these do the sugar worked his
magic turn down the gas and add a couple
of tablespoons of fresh extra-virgin
olive oil let them stew for two to three
minutes now I want to make the peppers
nice and light and sort of sweet
aromatic just roll the basil almost like
a big cigar slice basil in and then
literally cook it out for 30 seconds and
one ham off
beautiful okay turn back on now for pork
chops I'll make sure they don't curl up
in the pants they start coming up in the
pan they're gonna cook unevenly a few
simple cuts through the Rhine means the
Chop stays flat and cooks evenly put the
knife down flip through this seasonal
beautifully nice large shards of pepper
punch that through lightly guaranteed
that seasoning is gonna stay there hot
pan Dutch garlic and such a time and the
garlic take a couple of cloves don't
peel it don't chop it just knife on
crush it olive all in just startin to
smoke top of the chop in lay away from
[Music]
nice
keep that heat in the pan the garlic in
there early and I sprang a bunch of
thyme see how the poor could stay nice
and flat turn it over time underneath
there start squeezing that garlic out I
want the flavor coming out butter in
thin slices of butter tilt the pan and
baste so I'm sort of speeding up the
cooking process at the same time I'm
keeping the pork chop really nice and
moist and now look at the color that
butter some ways nice sort of a
nut-brown check the color on the other
side useful when that thick between a
half to four minutes each size 30
seconds from now they're gonna be medium
so I'm gonna take them out and let them
rest
the secret to perfectly moist pork chops
is letting them rest almost as long as
they're cooked in their pan
a nice spoon of these peppers the basil
smells incredible did that garlic on
there be generous with that vinaigrette
from the peppers because it really is
incredible
do two things simple like that pork and
peppers and your conference is going to
shoot through the roof
a stunning pork chop with sweet sour
peppers loin of pork rich sumptuous is
the most tender part of the pig this is
better when it's slightly pink yes
that's right granny pink first of all
you have to score that fat on the
outside you get some really nice crispy
crackling score if you haven't got a
sharp knife I mean really sharp you just
Stanley knife it works brilliantly stuff
just slice into the center and open it
up and look
lemon zest it gives it a really nice
summery zesty lightness sage sage and
pork go brilliantly well together
parsley garlic nice little thin shards
salt pepper olive oil like a blanket of
aroma fold it over just like an envelope
time
put the string in the pot to stop it
running around
salt pepper olive oil mop it up it
smells amazing it's not even cooked yet
straight in hotter than 45 minutes man
that is amazing look crispy crackling
rest
untied
carve nice thick slices that's what I
like to hear that noise
crispy correctly
tender and delicious
fragrant lemon zest with the sage and
the past extraordinary pot loin with
lemon and sage done take a very sharp
knife bring the pork belly towards you
so you're over it you've got all that
pressure and weight using the tip of the
knife I'm just sort of nicking it they
go across the pork belly long strokes
with a knife take your time
turn it 180 this time what we're doing
is just sort of cutting it was nice
little sort of diamonds but as that
starts roasting on top it starts getting
nice and crispy take handfuls of salt
and just sort of rub it in bend it over
in in those cracks really helps to get a
nice crisp crackling on top roasting
tray getting really nice and hot take a
whole / fennel to intensify flavor and
to keep the meek succulent and braising
my pork belly with strong vibrant spices
and vegetables crush and peel three
whole cloves of garlic and add to the
fennel olive oil in
pennilyn I like the nice strong aniseed
flavor that go to that nice rich dense
poor fennel seeds delicious star anis in
just a couple of - cardamom seeds Wow
they're like little banners like little
firecrackers incredible lovely fresh bay
leaves get your pork skin side down just
[Music]
sear the top of that fat that locks in
all that amazing flavor then I'm gonna
flip it over and get it nice and crispy
and then on fennel seeds embed it in
those little cracks now some white wine
the minute that white wine hits that
pine you can you smell that
lights fragrance and with fennel I'll
have the wine to bubble away and reduce
until the alcohol has burnt off time
that the stock now the stock goes in
just underneath the skin so it roasts on
top all that meat under there are we
submerged because what happens in the
oven the top goes crispy as anything and
the stock reduces and braises at the
same time really importantly bring that
back up to the ball before it goes in
the other otherwise it will never boil
and never get up to temperature smells
incredible
slow-roasted pork belly at 180 degrees
for two and a half hours look at that
you got that nice crispy skin on top you
can see how much of the stock has
evaporated
without on to the board it looks
stunning to make a delicious rustic
sauce with the flavor packed contents of
the roasting tray first get rid of the
excess fat take a couple of slices to
press it's like a perfect sponge because
you just lay that on top drag it almost
like a net and it just absorbs all that
fat if you want the perfect fry bread
trust me let's stick that in a fine pan
a nice teaspoon of mustard whisk that in
and then simply simmer for a few minutes
before pouring into a serving jug
[Music]
with your pork belly always use a nice
serrated edged knife you can hear that
[Music]
that is amazing incredibly tender that
belly of pork is gonna almost melt in
your mouth you've got that sweet meat
under that crispy belly of pork what an
amazing way to cook a very cheap cut of
meat
[Music]
mouth-watering
smoky pulled pork with a spicy chipotle
mayonnaise that is the most amazing pork
but that's the way butts all right now
this is incredible
there's the Charlotte look there's the
shoulder blade if you go through here
there's a knuckle there that's
connecting the top and that's why it's
called a but the slow you cook it the
more juice here is and it's great for
big parties because you just come along
and get you fork and shred it a
delicious smoky mayonnaise and you
knowwe onions into half and half again
again they leave the roots on I care
because I want this to sit underneath
the poor it gives it a chance to cook
evenly and doesn't get dry in the bottom
really important okay no I'll peel the
garlic okay I'd like you to crush the
dog we're gonna make a really nice
little paste okay y'all make it nice
good girl oh gosh Tommy cut there now
this is a beauty smoke so three nice
tablespoons in okay two large
tablespoons of brown sugar salt please
pepper
okay so gonna form a nice paste now
olive oil in mixed that some time in
there so we got a sort of fragrant rub
time stalks underneath so that's the
more flavor going on the bottom pour
that all over now
this is my gonna be really quick okay
let's rub that nice sergeant in almost
it's exactly that it smells amazing
mostly just drizzle a little touch of
olive on top of that for me we keep the
pork nice and moist lovely like some of
the best party dishes the marinating the
pork shoulder can be done days in
advance so if I wasn't doing this for
Sunday and start marinating Thursday
Friday so it gets even tastier it's very
easy
five-and-a-half to six hours in the oven
at 1:41 I fought but slowly roasted meg
and I are gonna pimp some shop-bought
mayonnaise
I don't like just plain mayonnaise
there's so many things yeah there's so
many things somebody excitedly can do
with it right
salt pepper and a touch of honey sweet
sweetness but there's some heat coming
okay and I've got a little bit of you
know this Chipotle smoke to pull a heist
once you've made this dressing you know
it can sit in the fridge
great for Oakland sandwiches yeah any
senators but goes brilliantly well with
pork now just have a little taste
I've never had this before it's so good
and I spoon of mustard so that's a nice
spicy mayonnaise
after five and a half hours in the oven
and pork is nearly ready just time to
knock up a couple of tried-and-tested
party favors first deliciously simple
cheesy crushed potatoes cut potatoes
into even chunks and submerge in salted
boiling water skins and all meanwhile
finally those sweet pickled gherkins or
Cornish ons trim and finely chopped
spring onions then grate some nutty
Greer cheese when the potatoes are
cooked through drain roughly crush and
add your spring onions and gherkins
season to taste and gently combine
before a final sprinkling of grated
Greer these simple cheesy crush potatoes
are equally delicious served hot or cold
now I want something sort of raw like a
slaw something quite refreshing so I'm
going to make a really nice fresh
broccoli salad now these are called
florets that's the best part of the
broccoli
okay the bitter everybody wants once
they're off and you slice the broccoli
okay never had broccoli before I always
think when you dress this with the
dressing it's incredible
now little seasons early on yeah now for
the dressing fresh yogurt in teaspoon of
sugar please that it's not cider vinegar
yeah fine it's optional in with the
broccoli so delicious roasted always
into the pocket that gives that nice
sort of chewy texture right lift up your
bowl please
nice and gently half of that in the
middle please thank you and stop and
then mix that up with me
kick you a little taste
so good and it's kind of salad that
doesn't wilt cover hours later it's
still crunchy cuz I brought these raw
raw broccoli salad Chipotle and I let me
the pork out this look at this
Megan honestly that is amazing it's
beautiful
that isn't close
[Music]
now that goes the table like that it's a
mission of a tiny bit before we go to
the table mega a little bit honestly
don't tell mom thank you oh good idea
oh my dear
that is incredible sorry you promised me
you don't do the rest me to a boyfriend
[Music]
this is my ultimate easy party dinner
melt-in-your-mouth slow-cooked smoky
pulled pork with a spicy - poly
mayonnaise and quick simple sides of
crushed cheesy potatoes and a light and
healthy broccoli slaw